un courriel de l'institut national du
sport du québec dont radio canada a
obtenu copie a été envoyée aujourd'hui à
tous les athlètes et au personnel
affilié aliens s on y indique que
laurence vincent-lapointe prenez quatre
sortes de supplément le nutritionniste
en chef de lyoness a adressé cette mise
en garde
il est fortement conseillé de cesser
l'utilisation de ces suppléments tant
que de nouvelles vérifications ne soit
fait
une information que nous a confirmé son
responsable des communications
les terrains de sport effectivement
transmis de façon générale aux athlètes
entraîneurs et reconnaître le souci qui
il était finie une mise en garde à
l'égard de sur un produit par ailleurs
le pendant pacifique de l'institut
québécois l'institut canadien du sport a
lancé la même mise en garde
en lisant ces important avertissement on
peut raisonnablement se questionner sur
le nombre de produits qui circulent dans
le monde du sport et sur leur
authenticité mais également si des
athlètes ont l'encadrement nécessaire
pour les prendre en toute sécurité
poudre vitaminé créatine boissons
énergisantes la panoplie des suppléments
nutritionnels sportifs semblent infinies
la toile regorge de publicité vantant
les mérites de ses produits pour les
athlètes de haut niveau
l'intérêt de plus en plus grandissant
pour ces compléments se résumerait à une
phrase un plus c'est un plus les raisons
de leur utilisation sont diverses allant
de la récupération plus rapide les
bienfaits pour la masse musculaire et
même jusqu'à la superstition si j'ai
gagné une telle compétition c'est parce
que j'avais pris des suppléments le
ligand drôle qui serait à l'origine du
test positif de laurence
vincent-lapointe occupe une place de
choix chez les athlètes sans même qu'il
sache s'il a un réel effet et plus grave
encore si peut être contaminée selon
christiane ayotte spécialiste mondial de
l'antidopage
mais dangers sont réels 10 à 15% des
suppléments alimentaires vendus
librement sont contaminés cette
contamination peut aller de simples
impuretés à des quantités importantes
d'hormones de croissance et
d'anabolisants
il ya toute la question est ce que c'est
vraiment nécessaire tous ces suppléments
là est-ce qu'on joue pas avec le feu
c'est une question qui
qui est très valide pour tous les
athlètes encore plus inquiétant l'étude
commandée en 2012 par le centre canadien
pour l'éthique dans le sport révélait
que neuf athlètes canadiens sur dix
consommer des suppléments et pour 50%
d'entre eux de manière quotidienne pour
les athlètes à la recherche d'un élixir
miracle le parcours n'est pourtant pas
simple tellement le marché est rempli de
suppléments corrompu il faut un travail
méticuleux rigoureux pour lire et
déchiffrer les étiquettes qui ne sont
pas toujours fiables
c'est ce que dit avoir fait la
championne du monde de canoë c'est un
peu paranoïaque sur les bouteilles d'eau
jeter ça même à mag ont traîné j'utilise
une bouteille d'eau ou verts qui restent
et se comptent encore la nutritionniste
mélanie olivier travaille depuis plus de
deux décennies avec les plus grands
athlètes canadiens il faut vraiment être
vigilants et s'assurer quand même de la
provenance mais comme dans le milieu
alimentaire
parfois c'est très très complexe et oui
il ya des failles d'un système alors à
qui profite réellement ces suppléments
sûrement pas la performance sportive
selon les chiffres d'agriculture canada
a publié en 2010 la valeur estimative du
marché mondial des produits de nutrition
sportive atteint 5,3 milliards de
dollars canadiens ici robert frosi rade
canada montréal